eh ben je suis prêt bref on jan et mon
cher et 1000 1 mondial vous êtes sûr
qu'il n'y a aucun danger
1 je n'ai jamais fait l'homme grenouille
là il faut être très prudent mais ne
vous inquiétez pas je suis là très bien
avant bonjour qu'est ce que ça en soit
je les dis qu il ya casimir aimé mon
vieux mais que se passe t il les estime
à près de ma mort oui des mamans avec
des nageoires à d'été marine au nom
d'emma mardi martin méchant monde
démarre tout - réprimer chaud enfin
qu'elle veut te makasi vie rozier qui va
rencontrer des marques et alors montfrin
casimir tu ne va tout de même pas nous
dire que tu as vu d merci c'est ils
m'ont même dit bonjour
oh ça c'est ce qui s'est passé tu as dû
lire hier soir un libre sur les martiens
et sec mais qu'a fait un cauchemar mais
non je les fais plus comme je vous vois
ils sont tous noirs avec des pieds comme
ceux des canards et plus qu'un concert
c'est un groupe comme les éléphants mais
qui se tient tout droit au dessus de
leur tête
voilà casimir a peut-être voulu nous
montrer des martiens rendez-vous qui ce
jeudi il casimir a beaucoup
d'imagination et puis depuis quelques
temps casimir casey mears comme ça et
quel est le dernier livre que tu as lu
le dernier dans ces c
et les martiens débarque nom a tancé les
monstres aux joueurs d'aller marcher a
débarqué hier me demande tout ça et bien
justement casimir comme depuis quelques
temps du lit uniquement des livres où il
est question de monstres et
d'extraterrestres et que le matin tu
n'es pas toujours très bien réveillé eh
bien tu crois avoir des martiens partout
mais en réalité il n'existe que dans ton
imagination et alors pistolet ghezzal
operator je vais inventer potec v
casimir si même des martiens sont venus
sur l'île aux enfants
je ne vois pas pourquoi il serait de
mauvaise intention mais julie a
parfaitement raison casimir
moi je suis certain que tu es fameux
marcia sont très gentils et nous devons
tout faire pour leur souhaiter la
bienvenue
on voit bien que vous n'avez pas lu les
mouches travers de l'espace enfin
puisque vous me croyez je veux bien
faire un effort
je vais aller leur préparer un gloubi
boulga gigantesque avant ça c'est une
excellente idée d'installer un casino
givet non invasive et lobo bon enfin un
givet alors soyez prudent n'attaquait
pas nous ouvrons l'oeil toucan
gloubiboulga je ne sais pas si les
mercis interprétons ça comme un geste de
bienvenue
on ne sait jamais il trouvera peut-être
ce plat très beau tiens voilà monsieur
du snav est le facteur qui reviennent de
leur parti de plongée ce mal bonjour
monsieur du snob et bonjour factor mais
vous êtes déjà de retour au haut la main
mais vous avez les réviser que vous
arrive-t-il
asseyez vous asseyez parole surtout pas
voilà tout mais pas ça les femmes
arrêtent et georgi 12 avril mosher emile
raconter leurs ébats
nous sommes levés ce matin de bonne
heure
nous nous sommes habillés en grenouille
tiens d'ailleurs nous
on croise et casimir ah oui c'est vrai
une petite seconde facteurs vous dites
que vous avez croisé kazemi en avant et
nous a même paru bizarre je les mets là
voilà l'explication kazimi on vous a
pris pour des martiens et on voit
monsieur du seul habit on pense plus à
un martien qu'un homme grenouille
quant à vous mon cher et 1000
il est vrai qu'on pense à une grenouille
bien celle de la fable qui veut se faire
aussi grosse que le boeuf
mais voyons monsieur qui soit facteurs
le débat reprenez votre récit bon bon et
bien voilà nous étions un peu fatigués
nous avions décidé de nous assoir
gentiment là au milieu des rochers au
bord de l'eau ou attention je serai bien
merci mais je perdrais d'attention
précis qu'est ce que c'est
françois et je voulais en grande
discussion avec les martiens il était
temps que j'arrive qu'elles signent à
casimir du tombe bien laisse moi te
présenter le martien emile campagne et
le martien monsieur 10 nov
tu vois que j'avais raison enfin quasi
mur qui ne va pas continuer tu vois bien
qu'il s'agit de monsieur 19 et de notre
bon facteur où on va on voit bien que tu
n'as pas lu les envahisseurs sont parmi
nous parce que tu saurais que les
martiens sont très intelligents et que
pour envahir l'île aux enfants qu'ils
ont pris l'apparence d'habitants de
l'île n'est enfin casimir mais que
faut-il faire pour te prouver que ce
sont bien emile campagne et monsieur du
stock qui sont là devant toi bon eh bien
deux longueurs de s'asseoir
c'est tout oui parce que dans 2 dans
l'est les monstres ne plie pas on
explique que les martiens sont claires
elles
et qu'ils peuvent tout faire sauf
s'asseoir alors s'il passe
victorieusement cette épreuve 10 ans
convaincu absolument
messieurs s'il vous plaît asseyez-vous
veille à beaugeay selon sinistre je suis
désolé ma chère amie mais la dernière
fois qu'emile campagne et moi même nous
sommes d'affi nous avons été comment
dirais-je ont piqué au vif
qu'est ce que nous voulons dire à
expliquer leur mon cher ami vous qui
connaissez les petits coins où il fait
bon s'asseoir et bien voilà comme nous
étions assez fatigué nous avions décidé
de nous reposer et nous nous sommes
assis malencontreusement sur un ennemi
dont st oui c'est qu'est ce que c'est
des oursins maintien regarde wild-card
oui d'accord ce sont ces petits animaux
qui vivent dans la mer accroché sur les
rochers pour exactement casimir des
bosses il est maintenant je suis
convaincu parce que il ya que monsieur
du snob et le facteur pourrait être
aussi bête mais tenez ça valait mieux un
peu de goût des bulgares et tout ira
bien au non comme un soir
ouais
voilà